The Joe Rogan experience,
your childhood was fucking completely bizarre.
I mean my childhood was bizarre on paper,
but it wasn't bizarre in front of the whole world,
you know?
And you became a fucking superstar when you were a little kid.
You're 40 now,
right?
District for.
Okay.
I'm 43.
So when I saw the champ,
I think I was seven.
What would you like for?
No,
no,
I was seven.
So you were 10 and the champ.
Really?
Okay.
My,
my time,
Ron,
but either way.
Either way,
whatever I was seven or 10,
I was fucking crying like a baby.
And you were even younger than me then.
So when I was a little kid,
when I was like going through life,
trying to figure out,
you know,
what my parents were breaking,
I'm going to try to figure out like fuck,
what is life all about?
You were fucking famous in front of the world.
Like I couldn't imagine that point in my life being famous.
That must have been so strange to develop in that.
But you're so normal.
Well,
here's the thing that's interesting about like growing up famous,
because I became famous when I was like seven,
so I don't have any memory of life before fame.
Wow.
So when that happens and you're forming and you're getting programmed and you're
getting created as a child,
right?
Um,
that's what becomes normal for you.
And so I don't have any frame of reference like I wasn't 30 and all of a sudden
Bam became famous and I had 30 years of history of normal life.
So fame is normal for me.
So because it's normal,
that means kind of,
it's not special because what's normal is normal.
Right?
So that's kind of,
I think at different unique thing about being a child actor.
Like I wasn't.
I saw drew barrymore last night.
I went to never heard anybody put it that way before I went to her premier last
night and she,
she's kind of done the same thing and um,
her new movie and gave her a big hug and kiss.
I haven't seen her in 20 years to grab her ass and not just cheat girl though
you get rid of case.
I've known her since I felt good.
I was,
I'm 12,
I'm on felt good.
She was eight.
We would dance Tom Green.
That got that.
You could get that to kid.
So drew the same thing.
It's been a few of us that have gone through that,
like not many.
Very,
very few.
I could count on a hand.
Yeah.
The percentage of people who go through that and get Lindsay Lohan or like,
it's like 95,
right?
Yeah.
More.
More than maybe.
What do you think was the difference with you?
Uh,
what's the difference?
You know,
I quit the partying thing when I was young and I didn't continue it.
Like I think some people do and you know,
I had my few wildly years between 16 and 20,
but you know,
I always kept my kind of stuff quiet and I kind of kept it under the radar and
you know,
it wasn't really public about it.
And then I met that was because there was no TMZ.
There's no internet,
no Internet sun and keep it on the dl rotors here making it rain.
Do you ever wonder when I was 20 I met Andrea and that just kinda changed my
life because I was,
I was a dad at 22.
Oh.
So that's a big part of it,
too.
Responsibility.
Very early on.
Now.
Did you used to hang out with all those people back in the data?
Like Gary Coleman and all those guys,
like,
like were you like hanging with punky brewster and stuff?
Yeah,
I knew everybody there.
I mean the different strokes kids.
We're filming next door.
The facts of life.
Girls were across the,
the other studio stage.
Did you guys move at each other?
Who's the boss?
Kids.
Did you guys Bang Tryna?
You must've,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
It's small.
It's small wonder ustream crowd knows what's up,
so yeah,
there was some drama going on,
on,
on set.
You know what I mean?
There was.
I told you a little bit about the todd bridges than.
Yeah,
todd bridges.
I had,
we had todd bridges on fear factor and he had a chip on his shoulder.
I mean,
not,
not.
I mean,
wasn't a bad guy,
but had this thought that everybody was out to fuck them,
that everybody,
like we were fucking them over like we didn't want them to win.
Oh,
I see.
What's up.
You don't want me to.
When I was like two,
but the guy or the guy beat yet.
What am I going to say?
Right.
Come on man.
It's ridiculous.
But he's got a new book out,
so like God bless him.
I hope he sells it and stuff,
but.
Well he just,
you know,
he didn't.
My point is he did not get through it the way you got through.
He was chasing me around with a pistol full of urine.
Wow.
Water pistol full of urine.
It was really.
He was.
Yeah.
I mean he was pissing a water pistol and then just say,
okay,
I'm going to score it because the rest of us would be thrown water cups at each
other and crap.
And he took it to the next level and just started sweating.
It was urine
random over with your training.
He was big and he was older.
We were all scared of todd.
How old was he?
And we were all like 13,
14 and he's all like 18,
19.
Oh my God.
He was 18 and 19 years.
Pissing little kids faces.
Yeah.
Kelly was the originator of that.
He had a porsche.
Right.
And so he was racing around the studio and stuff and I remember I was 16 and I
had just gotten my nine,
44 turbo and he's like,
let me take it for a drive.
And I'm like,
oh,
okay.
So I gave him the car keys and he's like,
this thing is broken and right.
Wow.
Just abused my car.
He brought it back with bald spots on the.
Wow.
Well you let them do that.
Went to todd bridges.
Yeah.
Well todd bridges.
He wasn't a bad dude though.
He's just so.
He's just a fucking baby.
That got stuck into a weird situation.
It didn't develop.
Dana.
Plato became a drug addict,
right?
Yeah,
she died in Vegas.
That's the place to die if you're going to die with other drug addicts.
The disease.
Segal finds its flock.
Can I place it?
This quote that I was talking about earlier?
Oh yeah.
This is silver spoons is from I love,
I love silver spoons,
but this is one of my favorite quotes and it's so weird to listen to you right
now.
Listen to this.
Listen,
this
looks like the recording.
This is crazy.
See computers the way feature people already playing
someday.
People that do all their banking or shopping with computers Sunday almost every
lifting to be done by a computer.
Well that's nice.
But um,
what do you need special stories like can you mess with me and took with this
thing,
Jackson trying to steal money lets me and Gary Coleman.
So listen to what you were saying man.
You were saying that like,
was it 19,
83 season one
it man,
you guys on,
you shut the power off.
I'm back anyway.
Um,
so how,
how did they fucking predict that?
So?
Well,
uh,
it's Kinda creepy.
Like did you guys get like computers?
I'm like steve jobs or stuff like that.
They all like.
Because that whole show was about computers.
Did you have like the inside word where you are your profit target?
No,
I don't know.
You're Mormon.
You will be a profit video games man on set and stuff,
so I don't know about the computer thing.
I know as a kid how crazy you were.
Like you were like kid porn for us.
You were like,
dude,
he has a pac man machine.
He has a train.
You've got every single toy in the rural.
And it was like we idolized you as kids at our age group.
I'm 36,
so it's like I had I think duck phone.
I had like a remote control from your whole with Mr Aaron gray man.
If there was a tmz back during gray,
what would,
what would they have caught you doing?
Uh,
what would that be?
Popping bottles.
Hanging out of the hotel.
Roosevelt with Alfonzo and Corey Haim and Corey Feldman back in 1986 87.
Roosevelt wasn't nice.
Really.
It was a dive.
Wow.
What was back then was a dive club Hollywood.
You remember the hotel Roosevelt a super cute.
I remember.
I remember hearing about club Hollywood,
you know,
back in the day,
like teen bop magazine Hollywood.
That was so weird,
man.
Haim's dead.
Nobody saw that coming,
so.
Oh,
how weird is it that there's these kids that grew up with you that didn't make
it through the net?
How weird is that to watch?
Um,
yeah.
It's,
I feel really bad for the kid,
like Corey Haim that you knew when he was a little kid.
Yeah.
He was so good too,
you know,
when he was little then when the two of them weren't.
But was that fucking vampire movie?
The Lost Boys.
Just boys.
They were good in those movies.
He was a good actor.
Yeah.
So you must have hung out with Michael Jackson.
And what did they taste like?
You remember that kid ever finished?
Yeah,
I mean he was a real talent.
Fuck.
That was crazy.
Dying on sunset strip.
You know?
What about Michael Jackson that used to hang out with them?
Michael Jackson visited the set of silver spoons.
Wow.
What was that like?
He was friends with Alfonzo.
Who was my buddy on silver spoons.
You know Fonzo who was on the fresh prince right after source.
And what's his last name again?
Roberto Rivera Alfonzo.
So yeah,
he came to visit one day,
Michael Jackson and I'm hanging out with Alfonzo Alfonzo commercial.
That was when he was the biggest star on the planet ever.
Huge.
Yeah,
huge.
It was.
That was going to tell about my book and that was like three made me very
uncomfortable.
Oh really?
Did he didn't kiss on the lips?
He was bullshitting.
He's Michael Jackson estate lawyers down.
Do you think he fuck kids?
Um,
you must have heard stories.
I don't know about anal,
but I think it might be a set.
Might've been some inappropriate stuff if I had to guess like some handjobs
webster pull you aside and was like,
don't go to webster.
Really?
I heard so many rumors about Michael Jackson and why he's,
he's,
you know,
why he was the way he was.
But you were actually there.
What was he like?
Like where you have for this kind?
I want it to mean no funds that went to the universal amphitheater,
wants to see him play.
And we went into.
Is this was like Billie Jean Times?
Yeah,
this is the time.
So she on top of the fucking point,
biggest planet starting the universe,
and so,
um,
we're hanging out in his trailer and um,
you know,
just hanging out really nice quiet,
shy guy.
And so I'm like 16,
17.
I said,
Michael,
what's know,
how did you make it from a kid actor to an adult like this,
you know,
how did you survive?
Because I was kind of in the middle of transitioning from a kid to an adult.
And he said,
you know what,
the trick was being inspired ricky,
because I had to be inspired to keep it up.
And I had to find stuff that I wanted to work on and wanting to do.
And,
you know,
I,
I kind of took that advice to heart,
you know,
but no,
nothing ever inappropriate.
And he started kissing her nipples.
Nothing inappropriate rap with me or that I know of.
Hello?